OK so, at the end of this last section,
I canceled our party,
and said that we have this algorithm
that
works really well in practice on
theoretical spectra.
But the issue is going to be that when
we move to experimental spectra,
we're going to have issues
because these experimental spectra often
produce errors.
Here are the theoretical
and an experimental spectrum for the
peptide NQEL.
The theoretical spectrum is on the top,
and then
we're giving you a hypothetical experimental
spectrum for the same peptide.
This experimental spectrum highlights a
couple of different ways
that the experimental spectrum can be
flawed.
It can detect “false” masses.
These are masses that are present in the
experimental spectrum
but that don't correspond to real masses
in the theoretical spectrum.
Examples are 99 and 299 here.
We also have “missing” masses.
They're masses that are in the
theoretical spectrum of the
correct peptide but that don't actually
get produced in the experimental
spectrum,
so they're “missing”.
This is a problem, because our current
implementation,
in order for it to consider a peptide
correct, the peptide's theoretical
spectrum has to exactly match
the experimental spectrum that we have,
and that's clearly not the case here.
The question then is what do we do.
What we're going to do is, instead of
having to match the spectrum exactly,
we're going to instead “score” a peptide
based off
of how similar it is to the experimental
spectrum.
For example, here,
the theoretical spectrum of NQEL is still
pretty
similar to the experimental spectrum that
we have.
Notice that it shares 11 masses.
So, we're going to say that the score
then,
of NQEL, with this experimental spectrum,
is equal to 11.
We need to use this scoring function
to say certain peptides are better than
others
and to use this to modify the branch and bound
algorithm
that we have in order to make it a little
bit better.
The idea that I want to use here is
similar to something called a “cut” in a
golf tournament.
Now I'm a huge golf fan, so maybe
I'm just partial to this idea,
but I thought it fit it pretty well.
What the cut does, is it reduces the
field to
only the players that are deemed to be in
contention for the tournament.
So, if there are players, that are not
doing too
well after a couple of rounds, then, they
say,
OK, well, we're just going to let them go
home.
And, we want to have the tournament only
for the
players who have a chance of actually
winning the tournament.
Here's a hypothetical leaderboard,
and we may say, in this hypothetical
small tournament that
we want to keep the top three players on
the leaderboard.
Keeping in mind that low golf
scores are good, we put the cut line here.
But this would be unfair to this golfer,
right, because
they're tied with the third place golfer,
and so we
need to say, well we keep the top three
players…
…as well as ties.
So, keep the top three players “with ties”.
This is going to motivate the bound
step that we do.
So, after this cut,
we have four players remaining.
The new idea is, we're going to call it
LeaderboardCyclopeptideSequencing.
How it works is that we're going
to start off with a zero peptide.
So, this is an empty string, essentially.
And then we're going to extend
each peptide on the leaderboard
in each of 18 possible different
directions, so we
add each of the 18 different amino acid
masses
to the peptides that we have, currently,
in the leaderboard, which
when we begin is empty, or it has just the
zero peptide.
Then we're going to have this
“cut” step, which is the
new “bound step”, and it's going to cut the
low scoring peptide, so it says:
Assign everything a score,
see what the score of every peptide is,
and then cut the low scoring ones.
Get them out of there so that we can
prevent the number of solutions
that we consider from growing,
and so that we can keep only the high
scoring peptides.
So, we're going to keep the top N
peptides “with ties”.
Then, the next step is going to say OK,
we'll update the “leader peptide”.
We're going to keep track of
what the leader peptide should be,
and, if there's
a higher scoring peptide that we can find
on the leaderboard,
so if something moves up and becomes a
higher scoring peptide,
and its mass is equal to that parent
mass, that we can detect.
By the “parent mass” I mean
We said that we're always going to be able
to
know in advance what the correct mass of
the entire peptide should be.
So, we always want to check if these
candidate solutions
that we have have a mass that's equal to
that
total mass.
And then, we're going to eliminate any
peptides whose mass is going to grow too
big.
So, if their mass exceeds the
parent mass,
then, we're not going to want to expand
them any more, because
their mass is too big, and we want
to get rid of them, too.
So, once we do these steps, we're just
going to iterate these steps over and over
again.
So, we have a branch step, and then, a
bound step.
And then, we have an “update step”, where we
say, is there a leader?
And can we get rid of
anything whose mass has gotten too big?
At the end, after we go through this
procedure, we're going to branch and bound
and branch and bound,
it's actually going to guarantee to always
have an empty leaderboard at the end.
So, at step 6, after we go through
steps 2 through 5, we're going to have an
empty leaderboard.
And then, at that time we return, what is
our leader?
What's the best peptide that we've
encountered so far?
So, we have
this updated method.
But, I do want to give you the warning,
that it's what's called a “heuristic”.
Because it's dealing with high scoring
peptides, there's a chance that
there is an initially low-scoring peptide
that winds up eventually being
the highest scoring peptide, so that
eventually would be our leader,
but because we cut it in an early stage,
because, we said it's
not in the top however many N peptides,
then we throw it out.
And so there is a possibility that
we throw out
the correct peptide, or what will
eventually become the correct peptide,
at the expense of having a quick method.
And so for this reason it's a heuristic.
Let's test it though, because remember,
we're considering
how well these algorithms work in practice.
So, here is a hypothetical spectrum.
It has 10% false and missing masses.
I'll highlight where
the false and missing masses are.
So, here are the false masses, and here
are the missing masses.
Now, we're not going to know which of
these are false and missing to begin
with.
In particular, we're not going to have the
missing masses present.
That's the whole point.
They're not present in the experimental
spectrum.
So, we'll have this picture, but we won't
know which of the masses should be
green.
And then, we say, let's run our
algorithm, let's run
our leaderboard algorithm, on this
hypothetical data set, and see what it
churns out.
And so it returns the, the correct
Tyrocidine B1
peptide, which is where this came from, so
we're happy.
Then we say, well, maybe 10% false and
missing masses, maybe that was a little
bit optimistic.
So, let's introduce a slightly noisier
Tyrocidine B1
spectrum that has 25% false and missing
masses.
And again, I'll show you (even though we
won't know this)
I'll show you where the false and
missing masses are,
so you can believe me.
And, we can say, we won't know which
masses are missing.
Now, when we run that same algorithm,
on this noisier spectrum.
We're going to see that
the peptide that it produces
is actually not Tyrocidine B1.
It's close, but instead of the
correct amino acid here, It's been
replaced with an AD, so this is bad.
In this case, we wouldn't be able to
reconstruct the correct peptide.